[VIDEO GAME SOUNDS]
This is about 5%
of the collection.
It's a distributed archive,
so there are actually,
I think, 12 other
locations around--
mostly in the US, but several in
Europe and Australia, as well.
And so all of those places
have different items.
The things that we leave
here are things that
end up getting requested a lot.
Lots of historical games lots of
historical consoles and things
we leave out because
everything circulates,
so people don't
only want to see it,
they also want it to
be shipped to them,
which is an unusual thing
that we do in this archive.
We circulate things.
This is the Telematch Panoramic.
It's an Argentinean pong
system, mobile pong system.
So it was really designed
to be carried around.
As you can see, it looks like
a suitcase full of launch codes
for during the Cold War.
It's five games operated
with a push-button.
You have the instructions
here for playing Submarine
and Frontón and a kind of
volleyball game, a soccer game,
and a tennis game.
Frontón is kind of a pong game.
JUDD RUGGILL: There's
a lot of interest
in older games and
kind of replaying them
and in modern situations.
So what you have here is a
collection of basically arcade
classics all built
into one little device,
and it allows you to
play Ms. Pac-Man, Galaga,
I think Pole Position is on
here, Zevious, and Mappy.
KEN MCALLISTER: In its
day, none of those games
could possibly have
fit into a space
that small, let alone
5 or 6 of those.
[VIDEO GAME GUNFIRE]
JUDD RUGGILL: We both grew up
reading crappy science fiction
and fantasy novels, and they can
have a really profound effect
on the way in which
you see the world,
and the same is true for games.
Yeah, these things
are inspiring.
I mean, they build creativity.
They build imagination.
They shape our hopes and dreams
about what we could really do.
How many of the things
that we see around
our campus were inspired by
people playing video games,
by reading science fiction
as kids, reading comic books,
watching movies, watching TV
shows, and wondering, geez,
could I do that?
I wonder if we could
really do that.
And I think a lot of
times, the answer is yes.
Whoa!
[VIDEO GAME GUNFIRE]
KEN MCALLISTER: Well, I'm out.
VIDEO GAME VOICE 1: Here!
VIDEO GAME VOICE 2: Right here.